[Music]
foreign
something isn't right
I don't know what's going on
[Applause]
I need to find a way back yes
what to wear
what can you tell us about this wizard I
could take you to his castle beyond that
you're the ones intent on dying to run
run
angel
come to save us all
never seen anyone fight like that
you're a Wanderer
we have to kill them before they kill us
it's the only way to stop their Invasion
catch you said you wanted to prove
yourself this is the time
evil is as unstoppable
that's why we fight for those that can't
a good man knows that Darkness will
always be there and stands against it
anyway
foreign
world
[Music]
thank you